over the years
i have done a number of videos that i
class under philosophical developments
and commitments there's actually a
playlist devoted to those that i'll link
below in case you're interested in
seeing
more of these and one of my
interlocutors
on youtube recently pointed out that
although i
i talk a lot about him one person that
i've never done
one of those videos on is alistair
mcintyre probably best known for this
book
after virtue this is the second edition
though the one that i
originally bought i've also got the
third edition you can see
right behind me i've got quite a few
mcintyre works
and mcintyre is somebody with whom
i'm largely in an agreement and
admire in terms of both his his writing
and thinking
but also in terms of his character
because
he's somebody who i actually got to
work with and got to know somewhat
uh really about a decade and a half
ago and so i'm going to tell you some of
that that story and it's a complicated
story i'm not going to try to speak for
him
at all in this you know he's a living
philosopher
he can certainly do that on his own as
he's done at great length
and in many admirable ways from
place to place and time to time so
i'm going to begin the story by talking
about where i first heard of the guy
and then how i encountered his works so
when i was a graduate student people
would
mention him quite frequently especially
after i was moving out of my
like interested in philosophy of
language and super interested in
continental philosophy
and now picking up you know um
more let's call it traditional oriented
stuff like aristotelianism and the
stoics and thomas aquinas and people go
you probably
really like to read aleister mcintyre
and i was like well okay i'll get to it
eventually
and then on our prelims reading
list and our prelims are preliminary
examinations that we had to take at the
phd level back then the long since
phased out at
southern illinois university and at most
places you know throughout the united
states
we had these extensive reading lists
because we were in a pluralistic
department which meant that we had
representatives
of continental philosophy analytic
philosophy classical american philosophy
even some people interested in
history of philosophy and this this work
after virtue was one of the many books
on the list for ethics political
philosophy and aesthetics there were
probably about
30 to 40 books on the list that we had
to go over you know like john stuart
mills utilitarianism and
second critique and of course the
groundwork and you know we go on and on
and on
and so i started the summer that i was
preparing for that that
examination which by the way i got a
high pass on
which is kind of cool i picked up this
book which was available
at the
bookstore that i used to frequent that
i've talked about in some others that
was run
by two guys uh one of whom ended up
buying out the other one
it was where you'd go to get all the
independent stuff and all the cool
cutting edge stuff
um you know also you know rent
interesting independent videos and and
they had after virtue and so i bought
this
and started reading my way through it
and my experience with it was
one of those oh yeah this is
right up my alley this is this is the
kind of stuff
that i've been kind of groping towards
in terms of thinking about
you know what modernity is and moral
life
and contemporary culture this is the
kind of stuff that that i
have been you know kind of thinking but
but here's somebody who's actually
articulating it
and in a robust really solid way
and i i really enjoyed after virtue
and you know like like a lot of people
when you read something that you like by
a particular author you don't just stick
with that you go and see what else they
they've got and so it wasn't too long
before
you know we we got into the whole
we call it quadrilogy of mcintyre
and i've got it right here so you see
you've got after virtue
and then you've got who's justice which
rationality which was also kind of a
popular book being talked about quite a
lot when i was in graduate school
and then he also came out with three
rival versions of moral
inquiry which were his gifford lectures
if
you don't know the gifford lectures are
really one of the major
things as a philosopher it's sort of
like
being invited to do you know a
performance for
a whole bunch of other great musicians
if you're a musician
and then he'd also come out with a
dependent
animals the paul kerris lectures why
human beings
need the virtues and that's 1999 so
really all of these were
on all of these were available by the
time that i started getting into
mcintyre and i read them in succession
and studied them
over and over again and made a lot of
use of them so by the time that i was
getting out of uh graduate school
in 2002 i had read my way through
all of these and you know gotten a lot
of
mileage out of them i was also
um if i do i was i part of the
it's me at that time i'm not sure i'll
tell that that story a little bit later
but you know what's going on why do we
call this a quadrilogy because mcintyre
is raising some really important themes
in
after virtue then you know going back to
a lot of the same ground
you notice whose justice which
rationality is much larger
it's about like double the length of
after virtue and then
adding to the story with three rival
versions and then finally
bringing things to a close in dependent
rational animals
and you know this these are really
important works i think that this will
be
this sequence will be something that
will mcintyre will be known for
centuries from now they're very
important
and they have their resources in his his
earlier work which i'll talk about in a
minute and how i encountered that
and they also you know project forward
into the the work that he's
still you know cranking away at
at present and has done over the last
you know
uh really two decades you could say
so you know for me this is this is
really quite important and i do want to
say that i
you know there were their points where i
don't think mcintyre
has things entirely right but even when
he's wrong
he's usually wrong in interesting
provocative
ways that have a kind of openness
to them he's not like you know
somebody's got you know a lockstep you
know here's the way things were done and
here's how
everything fits together he's you know
he really thinks that a traditional
living tradition
has to have a kind of receptivity
to criticism and so you know
i was already you could say an admirer
of mcintyre and then
uh i had a a really unique opportunity
and this opportunity was to study with
him
and so how did that happen well you know
in the early days of the internet when
we were using dial-up modems and stuff
like that you know i i was
pretty involved in doing philosophy and
i was i was my first job i was teaching
at a maximum security prison
indiana state prison up in michigan city
i was teaching for ball state and i
i actually was teaching in a degree
program these prisoners would get
bachelor's in general studies and they
could minor in philosophy or religious
studies both of which i taught
i actually introduced them to mcintyre
there some some of the prisoners
and they they liked him quite a bit um
and i saw this this call for
participants you know you could apply
for the notre dame and i was spending a
lot of time at notre dame more mcintyre
was by the way
and he was associated with a
a center that i myself would go to the
events of the center for ethics and
culture
he was a fellow at the center i'd
already seen him speak
in events that the center would put on
these big conferences
and you know i was pretty impressed
with with him but i hadn't met him and
this erasmus institute faculty seminar
was this program
and it turns out that we were the very
last year the the program was running
out of money but they were putting this
on
and for two weeks they would put you up
at notre dame
and you would you know they give you all
your meals and stuff like that
and every single weekday you would study
with aleister mcintyre from about eight
in the morning
to about four in the afternoon taking a
break for lunch and he didn't go to
lunch with us
um but you know we we members
we faculty fellows got to talk with each
other as well
and so when i saw this i was you know
the other thing i'll mention too
all of these have some sort of focus now
mcintyre
if you don't know this he likes to do
things in threes he likes to
take you know we've got this book three
rival versions of moral inquiry right
mcintyre really does have a penchant for
taking
three different strands and comparing
contrasting them against each other
bringing them into dialogue with each
other
and for this erasmus institute seminar
the three that he was doing were
rational choice or decision theory
which was you know sort of a
contemporary way of looking at things
ties together with analytic philosophy
and ethics but also has its roots as he
was going to argue
in a human and also hobbsian way of
looking at things so we got one
version over there adam smith kind of
figures into it as well
and we actually had an adam smith
scholar as one of the people
then on the other side we had
aristotle and thomas aquinas you know by
then sort of stock and trade for for
mcintyre who
by the way did not start out as an
aristotelian he he came to that
and came to the atomist much later on
and then um the third one
which was kind of interesting and kind
of a surprise
was freud and le con
so psychoanalytic theory and not just
any psychoanalytic theory but you know
one of the originators makes sense sort
of like corresponding to aristotle
and then a great reinterpreter sort of
like thomas aquinas with
uh aristotle except it's lacana saying
we need to go back to freud and i saw
that and i was like
well i actually know all three of these
areas
um it's a chance to hang out with
mcintyre
and you know see what he has to think
about things and
let's do it so i applied for it and i
got accepted
and there were 12 of us if i remember
correctly and i was
pretty much the junior scholar there
there were a few people
who were you know maybe
around the same in in their career path
as i was remember i was only three years
out of grad school and actually
nobody was as junior as i was um i
hadn't published all that much
at that point and so i was kind of like
you know um
you know they call it the dark horse
right other people you could tell
why they were in the seminar like some
of them had studied with mcintyre before
had connections uh many of them had been
you know out there being professors and
publishing on stuff for
20 30 years there were a few younger
people but they were further along they
were getting close to going for tenure
and all of that and almost none of them
knew
much about freud and lacan the only
exception would be the one from
uh um who had researched paul recur
and was working on him um there were a
lot of people who knew a lot about
thomas and aristotle of course
and then there were some who knew a bit
about the rational choice theory i was
the only person who actually
knew about all three and i think that
played a role in my getting accepted i
also found out that one of the other
things
that got me accepted was that mcintyre
was genuinely interested
in my prison teaching and you know what
the prisoners were like and what they
were learning because mcintyre
is extremely interested in institutions
in ordinary people
in how things work in the messy world
that we
we live in so it was an amazing
experience
um you know we we started out each day
with this
you know breakfast together and then
we'd migrate over to this
this building i don't remember which
hall we were in you know notre dame was
as usual undergoing construction
uh so we had to you know sometimes
circum you know navigate the the campus
and uh you know then then mcintyre began
and he starts off by
you know saying we're going to talk
about these three rival versions let's
all introduce each other
and let's jump right in to thinking
about rational choice
or decision theory and where it comes
from what are its assumptions what what
is the way in which it treats desire
and so you know we went the entire time
i actually went home on the weekend
because i had you know
a young child at the time and i only
lived an hour and a half from notre dame
so i stayed there and then then came
back and
um you know i also took advantage of
being there at notre dame to
spend you know at least two hours every
day in the the hesburgh library doing
work
on one of my my main um
preoccupations at the time the 1930s
christian philosophy debates
um but i also hung out with the other
participants and you know
each of us had the opportunity to do
some one-on-one time with mcintyre i i
put that off because i lived nearby
to to later on and so we had this
amazing seminar
that lasted two weeks and you know he
was very interested not just in freud
and lacombe but also
as you would guess from if you read um
rational dependent animals and on a
freud and charles winnicott
and um i might be mixing up winnicott's
name i think i've done that in other
places
um but you know it was it was really
quite great and um
then afterwards you know i kept in touch
with some of the people
from the the seminar we each got to
present our own
stuff so i presented some stuff from the
1930s christian philosophy debate
mcintyre later on handed me a manuscript
and he said i don't know if you'll find
this useful but um
and you can't cite it or anything but
here you go and it turned out that one
of the
one of the translations that i had done
uh uh emil berrier
right uh and his important like kickoff
piece about uh the christian whether
there's christian philosophy
mcintyre had done one of his own for his
own students years back because he was
interested in these these topics
and uh he said you can like you know
check your translation against mine and
see you know
what whatever you think so so i did that
and um
then you know in in the the months to
come
after that i you know went back to
teaching at the prison the prison itself
was only about an hour
from notre dame so i would i would drive
down you know sometimes after work
and i got to meet with mcintyre at his
office you know we
chatted about things had lunch i asked
him
by that time actually these books
had come out the selected essays right
the tasks of philosophy selected essays
volume one
ethics and politics selected essays
volume two i did reviews of these
for octa philosophica i actually brought
them
and uh this is this is kind of an
interesting little little
tidbit here so i you know i said hey
would you sign the book
and he took me very literally and he
just signed his name
but that's that's mcintyre you know not
a lot of pretension
not a lot of uh extra stuff going on
and so you know after reading these i
was like hey
did you ever read gabriel marcel because
a lot of what you're doing
in in some of this stuff having to do
with like the body and all that
it's very similar to what marsala is
doing he said no
really i haven't read him much um you
know i'm not drawing on him there's
similar themes and so you know we talked
about that a bit he asked me about
maurice blondell who he really hadn't
read much of
and what there was available in blondel
that he might find interesting
i had just done my dissertation uh and
defended it in 2002 i'm blown down we
talked a bit about the christian
philosophy debates
we also talked about a variety of other
things and that was you know that was
quite nice
and i saw mcintyre um several times
later on while i was still living in
indiana
um at conferences and and every time i
i'd
run into him he'd come up to me and and
say oh how are you doing
and how how's your at that time you're
you're you know your one daughter and
and
how are things going with your your
publishing and he's very genuine guy
there's no there's no [ __ ] about him
and when it comes to virtue ethics you
can say that he's not just somebody who
talks the talk he really walks the walk
he is very interested in plain persons
he's not what you would call a respecter
of persons
in the biblical sense meaning somebody
who gives a lot of attention to people
who have
prestige or connections as opposed to
regular people and so
it's something i found incredibly
refreshing about the guy
but it makes a lot of sense if you look
at his earlier works and i've got a few
of his earlier works here
you know mcintyre for a long time was
you know he was trained in the analytic
uh you could call it tradition and he
sees the the deficits of that fairly
early on
he's also for a long time a marxist
and not sort of a doctrinaire
um carry around pictures of chairman mao
you know kind of
kind of marxist but somebody who thinks
that there's something
really there that has to be plumbed and
thought through and you know two great
works that kind of fit in with that
would be his against the self images of
the
the age essays on ideology and
philosophy
you can tell he was a younger guy the
time that is written by the
the pictures that they're using on it
and
um you know this is a quite interesting
stuff he's also got a great
book of selected essays on hegel that he
edited
and contributed hegel on on
bones and skulls if i remember there's
this great
little book herbert marcuza
and exposition and polemic this is the
kind of stuff that mcintyre
did you know he took he took things
seriously another that i i came across
when i started
writing on i was originally trying to do
something with the materials from
uh the seminar um he's got a book on
called the unconscious that he wrote
quite a while ago
and originally he was um
[Music]
he was uh
teaching a class right and so he said
i'll turn this into
a book and so this is quite quite
interesting
he's also well known for this short
history of ethics
which is quite good there's some gaps in
it of course
um but but it's it's you know it's very
interesting
and actually that's that's a good place
for me to segue into something
um there are gaps within mcintyre's work
he acknowledges that
he's got no problem saying that
and when there are those gaps he wants
to know
what's missing and what should be there
a lot of kierkegaard scholars actually
contributed to an entire edited volume
criticizing mcintyre's treatment of
kierkegaard
in uh his works and mcintyre responded
to them
you know anthony long wrote this
excellent piece about how you know
contemporary
and ancient stoicism really ought to be
understood
as a parallel to the aristotelian and
neo aristotelian tradition
that mcintyre is championing and
you know that mcintyre's take on
stoicism is essentially like you know
conscientism before it's time is
is is getting things wrong um and
mcintyre
you know is willing to say okay there's
something there i i actually myself
wrote a piece
uh a while back and and gave it at one
of the
um international society for mcintyre
and inquiry conferences
about how mcintyre is getting anselm
wrong and could be doing some very
interesting things
if he had thought of and some less in
terms of like the ontological argument
and more in terms of moral theory and
the reforms of the church and of
european culture
in the time that anselm was writing and
working and occasionally being exiled by
english kings
um i never sent that often i suppose i
should send it off to them you know
sometime
but you know those are the sort of
things where there's
you know gaps in the story but mcintyre
is happy to have those filled in he
you know got very interested in
phenomenology ends up writing a book on
edith stein you know
some of his other books that you know
we've we've got to
uh later on god a god philosophy
university is a selective history of the
catholic philosophical tradition
uh good work there ethics in the
conflicts of modernity this is a much
more
recent work uh from 2016
you know quite interesting as well
reconsidering
a lot of things he's constantly
rebuilding it and i think that's that's
quite admirable
i'll tell you just two more things and
then bring this to a close because this
is already getting a little bit long
so you know the one is that
i haven't myself been in touch with
mcintyre for for quite some time i've
meant to
write him from time to time but i also
figure he's
pretty busy and there's a lot of people
who make demands on his time and you
know i probably should you know write
him a letter of of thanks
not least because he actually you know
years and years and years ago after the
erasmus institute
he wrote me um a letter of
recommendation which which proved to be
quite helpful
for me because you know people were
impressed with the fact that i knew
mcintyre
had nice things to say about me
and so you know the last time that i
interacted with him
was about 10 years ago and i'd written
him a letter about
where i was teaching at the time
fayetteville state university
which was at that time the most
dysfunctional institution i'd ever seen
and i mentioned that mechner is very
interested in institutions
and goods and how people are served by
them or not served by them
and i wrote them this longish letter
about it you know and said listen i'm
i'm
actually trying to you know find a way
out of here and mcintyre
wrote me back and he said well here's he
wrote a lot of things but one of the
things that he said is
you know um it's too bad that you're
stuck in a place like that
but on the other hand it's really great
that you're stuck in a place like that
because the students deserve somebody
who actually
does care about their education and will
put in the time and work and i know that
you're that guy
so you know he's not just saying suck it
up buddy but he's saying
you know you might be the right person
at the right time
for getting some some good stuff done
for for that institution and members and
all that and i
i thought that was sort of your typical
mcintyre thing to say
the other thing i'll say is i've
mentioned um isme the international
society for mcintyre and inquiry
which was founded if i remember right i
want to say around 2006 or so
and i've participated in
i think three of their conferences
uh giving papers each time the first
time i gave a paper i'll put a link to
it below
was on mcintyre and
psychotherapy and psychoanalysis i gave
another paper
the one i mentioned about anselm saying
here's you know here's what we could
look at from
from anselm from a macintyrian
perspective mcintyre himself didn't but
here's what we could draw upon
and then the third one had to do with
prison education
and what we should make of you know
education in general and how we treat
incarcerated people and doing that from
a macintyrian perspective
as well and you know it's it's an
ongoing
institution uh
[Music]
haven't been very involved in it of late
because i've just been so busy but it's
something that i think
i might get back into because i had a
lot of you know good friends
in the organization some of them
aristotelians some of them marxists some
of them all sorts of other things
in between actually the last thing i
will tell you
that i think this is a great thing to
close on
so when it's me was founded
they did two things that i thought were
particularly good
one of which actually stemmed from
mcintyre so
the one thing that they did is they
would characteristically invite plenary
speakers who had some sort of beef some
sort of fundamental disagreement
with mcintyre so that we could get some
alternative perspectives and we weren't
just turning into like a mutual
admiration society the way a lot of
philosophical
organizations do that is
characteristically mcintyre
if you want your tradition to be healthy
it has to confront its critics
right the other thing was
as far as i know there's only been one
or maybe two times that mcintyre has
actually
gone to is me and that's by his own
choice
and you know so you could say was he
being a jerk there
no he realized that if he went to
to you know a society that's organized
around his thought
people would be looking to him for all
the answers and he didn't want that to
be the case
the exception that he made was if i
remember right when he turned 90
and they had a big celebration for him
great thing to do
and and so you know he did that that
time but the rest of the times
he doesn't mix in with that because he
wants people to develop
on their own without you know appealing
to
the master or you know looking to him
for all the answers he wants to promote
uh what we could call autonomy and true
discussion
and interpretation and i think that
that's something really quite admirable
and typically
macintyrian so that's a great thing to
close on
i think now i've made good on the
lack of previous discussion of this and
hopefully
you'll want to read mcintyre's works and
take on some of his thoughts
you